thopson was the third star of the
week after he led the league with
eight assists in four games here
comes dry Sidle with his new Winger
score that didn't take long throw Ryan Nan
Hopkins on his wing and suly Leon's got a
smile on his face 1 minute and 23 seconds
into the game shot that deflected off of
Chicago Defender this is a Matias atol 100 foot
pass to a posted up Warren Fogle Fogle collects
it and drops it to dry Sidle you see how deep
The Islander defense is borzo is back inside
the top of the circle that gives dry Sidle
plenty of room in full FL dry look at that
stick handling through the neutral zone Fogo
Newton Hopkins Say by sokan had dry on the
doorstep if he wanted one more pass he elects to
shoot it roen cleaning some snow out of his eyes
as watch his backhand feed from Fogle through the
seam to Newen Hopkins in you're right B doson and
Bard two of the best young defenseman offensive
minded in the NHL both right-handed shots real
strong players here's McLoud in front oh off
the post and out Ryan mlod with an excellent
pass his brother Michael's already scored
tonight for the Devils across the river in
Jersey certainly Ryan would like to get one
tonight just two goals for a cloud one an empty
neter Here Comes angal now angal turns away
looking shot saved by Skinner and here comes
McDavid in full flight three on two with nurse
the trailer nurse has it fired save by zoken
it's loose in front Hyman had a chance but knocked
away that's got to be terrifying when McDavid gets
30 40 ft in the neutral zone to skate and and the
bench is yelling keep the Gap they want to right
yeah good one coach it's going to be a tough match
up the Islanders if we mention injury riddled on
defense with this fast and right now looks like
energized Oiler team nurse mcdavis spins away
McDavid knocked away shot just wide bouncing
in front smacked by McDavid just wide nothing
and the boy the Oilers came close to making it two
nothing ilas SRO in the last line of defense with
McDavid and Hyman and Kane in his face keeps it
one nothing power play winding down now nurse one
more chance for the Oilers though to get a good
opportunity R shot into the glove of soken off
the Stick of EOL with 1 second left on the goer
penalty Obviously good skater veteran dude been
around a long time and a great shot block there
Lee quick shot on Skinner they just haven't given
him much Puck volume it was interesting in the way
they talked after they just they just felt this
team had a a little bit of confidence in their up
their sleeves McLoud lot of speed wrap around in
front rebound by Brown trying to get his first of
the year but soken denies Islanders on the Move
looking to get some offense down the wing rra
around no it's denied by Skinner Nelson thought
it was in but it stayed out and newon Hopkins
sauces to Fogo attacking the Nets Fogo shot saved
by soken back hand in front room for de AR R shot
tipped in front Fogle can't find it skard put the
Oilers back on their heels pageo almost chipped
it in he'd love to get a goal tonight pageo just
two goals shot just whistle wide another great
chance and maybe the islands are getting their
second win here backand in front nice save by
Skinner excellent save on pageo the cloud has
it though and here come the Oilers intercepted
bars up now in alone the ti of the game save by
Skinner the entire crowd came to their
feet save of the night is Matthew Barelle
who wears number 13 because his Idol was
pavle datuk one of the great puck thets in
the game barcel steals walks in so
Brown will join nen Hopkins the PK
has been very good under Chris nolock
opponent's just 3 for 36 on the power
play is threat though save by set a
rebound Anders Lee ties the game and
one and that moves Lee out of that front
of the net place but he knows where sprad
is buttered on as Lee has had a terrific
career from about 5T in front of the net
while he shoot it his strength is here he's
strong he can find the puck he gets inside a
Darnell nurse and for Lee to jump on the loose
P left-handed shot Nelson works his way through
one timer barzel is a little too hot for him it
got into his feet onetime Nelson fakes harbet
scar oh Bonos Snipes that was ripped in the
upper left hand corner look at this Puck
movement from the Islanders is barzel doson
and ele connect they move the puck All Around
The Zone this covers the entire width and depth
of the Zone Lee's got a goal and an assist this
is a great pass as he snaps it onto the tape of
bull Horvat who was the one NFL ref two minutes
for giving him the bu Ben d That's it he just
the business right there was a jet game too
that call was made Le you would know that Jet
fan shorthanded Paso will homesome do it again
yes holy snikes Holstrom has become a shorthanded
wizard Holstrom takes off with the loose Puck but
kajio set his head the hall away and as this goes
from Skinner's right to left he opens up and
Holstrom is going to slide this right between
his legs 10 goals on the year five of them
shorthanded oh he trying to make a pass that
time and here come the Oilers now again they're
on the power PL they need one they need McDavid
here's McDavid one-handed peny coming up will
this be a peny shot no it's holding it'll be a
five on three for 58 seconds it gets broken
up really nicely by Evan Bard now you've got
the Islanders going north now the puck comes the
other way and everybody is chasing McDavid good
luck and that left buard has it five on three
Oilers wrist shot high and wide of sokin had a
beat on that one dry settle out there with
McDavid now for a shift Dr SLE between the
legs to McDavid Sprints towards the net down
Lowman quick move shot Sav by soken can't find
it where is it McDavid tries to fish it
out there's the whistle he's tied up with
Hyman initially oh Hyman pushes his stick away
that's a penalty and when it goes undetected you
see barzel in front shot save by
Skinner baralo a streaking homom Off the
Bench Here Comes McDavid newon Hopkins
back here cander wide just didn't get it in The
Sweet Spot strong play by Romanov to read that
and to prevent that pass to dry cidal and front
shot save too loose hman can send it home kajou
clears power play over here comes atomo five
on five shot big save soken with the right pad
13 here's G shot just miss he had the upper short
corner Ryan now battling the blue paint but sokin
Dives on it and eats it up just be confident you
were an NHL player with confidence in the last
period just get it snap it there you go Roman up K
rebound oh two Saves by Skinner one on the initial
tip then the rebound on Lee who had two chances
after that disappointing effort in Montreal they
come back with a strong one tonight kind of
hold on at the end but two Power Play Goals